and joining me now with reaction from
Orlando is Roger stone a political
consultant and former Trump campaign
adviser Roger it is great to see you I
compiled that montage for you my team
did because I know you love to be
reminded of all the wit and wisdom and
prognostication skills of the
commentariat that routinely questioned
the president's mental fitness his
stability and so forth give us a sense
of what you believe is really going on
with someone like a Scarborough who used
to be a Republican congressman well the
first thing to understand here is that
all of this means that the Russian
collusion delusion has failed the
Democrats and their handmaidens in the
media having been able to produce no
evidence whatsoever of real Russian
collusion to assist in the election of
Donald Trump have now switched to Plan B
Plan B is Oh Donald Trump's crazy he's
mentally unstable he's nuts
no not at all he has his extra-sensitive
so did Harry Truman so did Theodore
Roosevelt so did Andrew Jackson in the
case of a guy like Joe Scarborough this
is just bitter jealousy the entire time
Joe Scarborough was in the House of
Representatives he told his aides and
his successor in Congress that he would
someday be President when Donald Trump
was nominated for president Joe
Scarborough thought he should be the
nominee
when President Trump chose vice
president pence for Vice President Joe
Scarborough thought he should be
vice-president
hilarya now that did that didn't stop
Joe and mica from brown nosing around
Marlo go in fact we now know it was mica
who recommended dina habib powell for
the deputy national security director in
the trump administration but at the same
time they have turned on him out of
bitterness this is the establishments
next narrative it is a precursor for a
25th amendment argument against the but
they want him out and i've said from day
one roger the first one i thought i
wasn't gonna win they thought
Billy Bush and McCain attacks and kazeer
Khan and also they kept predicting his
political demise and now they're going
with this wolf narrative that bolsters
their old narrative that the man is
unhinged I want to play something that
he said on The Today Show this morning
with Savannah Guthrie again this is
michael wolf who wrote this lurid book
let's watch the beginning it was like
every 25 or 30 minutes you would get the
same three stories repeated now it's the
same three stories in every 10 minutes
what are you arguing there I will quote
Steve Bannon he's lost it your reaction
to that Bannon according to this report
said he's lost it I've been around the
president I don't I mean I repeat things
I give speeches I get I say the same
anecdotes but repeating things and I do
people have a stopwatch Roger in there
this is just ridiculous
no I look unfortunately I wanted to give
Steve bin and the benefit of the doubt
particularly given Mr Wolf's long
history as a fabricator and a fictional
writer but unfortunately I think the
facts are in
you might chalk this up to animus if it
had happened after Steve Damon left the
White House but we learned that he was
saying these things while he was on the
White House payroll and he owed his
loyalty to Donald Trump the idea that
the president didn't want to win didn't
expect to win I spoke to him throughout
the campaign never once did he say that
he either didn't want to win and in
every conversation he was confident that
he would so I chalk the entire thing up
to it your typical inside the beltway
Malstrom where a political operative who
the voters have never heard of and don't
care about are trying to whip up a
narrative that is their plan B the Trump
presidency is unstable because the
president is nuts look in Lyndon Johnson
we had a president who actually
conducted White House meetings while
sitting on the toilet defecating but now
they're saying Trump is crazy no Trump
is the same solid citizen he's ever been
yeah he has his own style
- well and used it to win the greatest
upset victory in America Roger they're
so embarrassed they still are so
embarrassed and they're so angry that
they got it wrong and those clips will
not live on forever I'm gonna play those
clips or clips like it like you know
every week till I don't know how long
till you know and maybe we don't hear
from these people anymore but we have to
remind people of who routinely gets it
right and who routinely gets it wrong
Trump on issue after issue has
demonstrated they has more savvy and a
greater ability to connect with the
average voter than any of these
Manhattan Washington coastal elites
combined and and I think it just drives
them batty I want to read something to
you this is from Tony Blair Rodger and
he disputes a claim in the book he said
as the story about British surveillance
during the campaign that apparently is
in Wolf's book he says the story as we
pointed out his complete fabrication
literally from the beginning to end I
never had such a conversation in the
White House outside of the White House
with Jared Kushner or with anybody else
claiming that the campaign was under
British surveillance so another person
I'm probably not a big fan of the
president's may be saying the wolf you
know the wolf is howling at the moon
none of this is going to change anything
the Trump core constituency will remain
strongly behind the president as long as
he continues to keep faith with them on
the platform that got him elected we
have a record stock market we have
unemployment at historic lows a boom in
the housing market a solid conservative
on the Supreme Court Donald Trump's
making America great again and candidly
no but he really cares about what Steve
Bannon thinks Roger stone thanks so much